with so many big world shaking things
happening in every episode of Game of
Thrones it can be easy to overlook some
of the smaller moments here's a spoiler
filled look at some things only real
fans noticed in the final season of Game
of Thrones since the beginning of the
show Daenerys has adopted different
traditions and styles from the various
tribes and group she's led and joined
and perhaps the most influential group
in her young life is the Dothraki thanks
to the fact that she became a queen of
the warrior tribe upon her marriage to
Khal Drogo the Dothraki placed an
enormous importance upon the length and
style of their hair especially for the
men the more braids of man sports the
more victories he's won in battle and a
Dothraki warrior only cuts his hair if
he loses a fight so the longer the main
the more formidable the warrior when
Dothraki defeated in combat they cut off
their brain so the whole world considers
shame Khal Drogo has never defeated as a
result the Narus has sported a lengthy
Mane featuring a fierce tangle of braids
from several seasons but the fifth
episode of the eighth season finds
they're at a disadvantage having lost
two of her most trusted advisors Jorah
and missandei when Tyrion checks on her
at Dragonstone her braids are must
undone and ragged letting the audience
know that the Dragon Queen is losing her
grip and will end up risking everything
to get back on top when Daenerys was
married to the warrior Lord Khal Drogo
and Thrones his first season she didn't
anticipate having to fight all of her
own battles
mostly because Drogo a prideful and
formidable fighter was all too happy to
wage war on her behalf when Daenerys
told them she was pregnant with his son
who was prophesied to be a messiah like
figure known as the stallion who would
mount the world
Drogo made a passionate promise to take
the Iron Throne on Daenerys his behalf
[Music]
Shiva
boy that sort of violent destruction is
exactly what Daenerys and her Dothraki
horde unleashed on King's Landing in the
fifth episode of the final season it
seemed out of character until you
remember that Daenerys made a similar
pact with the Dothraki back in season
six and again Marty looks like she has
more than kept both of those promises
after losing her husband Daenerys made
several attempts to find armies and
benefactors to back her in the war to
come
and during Thrones the second season she
ran afoul of the Warlocks of Qarth who
stole her dragons and lured her into the
terrifying and mystical house of the
undying to get them back naturally
Daenerys charged into the temple to
track down her children and experienced
a number of visions along the way seeing
everything from her late husband Drogo
and their lost child to a battered and
seemingly destroyed Iron Throne standing
in an empty and ravaged throne room it
seems as if Daenerys is surrounded by
snow but thanks to the aftermath of
King's Landing in the wake of her
ruthless and murderous siege it's clear
that her vision has come true and it's
not snow but ashes many viewers always
believed that the snow was a sign at the
night king but perhaps at this point
Daenerys is raining a fire and blood is
even more dangerous and destructive than
the night King himself
and before long audiences will likely
see Daenerys standing in the real
ransacked version of the throne room
ready and determined to take whatever is
left of the Iron Throne itself check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]